[Aplausos]
[Música]
atentos os hago una pregunta cuál dirías
que es el mayor sueño de un
narcotraficante el mayor de todos como
papá papá pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa droga
guardar sexo pornográfico vamos a ver me
explico todos tenemos sueños tuyo los
políticos y desde luego los narcos no
son una excepción queridos amigos de
visual político aunque resulte difícil
de creer en el corazón de la despiadada
y cruel industria del narcotráfico hay
seres humanos con nombres apellidos y en
este caso también apodos que como todos
los demás mortales también tienen sus
propios sueños ahora bien cuál puede ser
el mayor de todos
supongo que respuestas posibles hay
muchas no os parece pues no no os
equivoquéis para desgracia de todos los
demás la historia nos dice que si los
narcos pudieran pedir un deseo tan sólo
un deseo éste no sería otro que
convertir a sus países en auténticos
narco estados es decir me explico en
estados dirigidos por una especie de
corporación delictiva formada por
políticos funcionarios públicos jueces
policías y militares
de una forma u otra estén asociados con
el narco de esta forma los
narcotraficantes pueden actuar
prácticamente con total impunidad
importando exportando y distribuyendo
narcóticos sin ninguna restricción
precisamente hace muy poquito tiempo
hablamos aquí en visual político de como
el régimen bolivariano de nicolás maduro
diosdado cabello y el cartel de los
soles estaba convirtiendo a venezuela en
todo un narcoestado sin embargo amigos
por desgracia en latinoamérica la
narcopolítica va mucho más allá de
venezuela en este vídeo vamos a conocer
un poquito mejor como un personaje fue
capaz de impulsar la alianza entre la
industria de los narcóticos y los
políticos atentos y leones amigos está
bien la comunidad de los tugurios en el
basurero municipal
[Música]
el narco populismo todos lo sabemos la
industria de los narcóticos es uno de
los negocios ilegales más importantes
cada año mueve varios cientos de miles
de millones de dólares ahora bien os
hago una segunda pregunta pensáis acaso
que un cartel puede sobrevivir sin apoyo
político sin controlar de alguna forma
las instituciones amigos para contestar
esta pregunta vayamos a los orígenes y
echemos un vistazo a cómo lograron poder
los narcos más importantes de todos los
tiempos porque si bien es cierto que en
sus inicios en el narcotráfico surge
como poco más que un grupo de bandidos
al margen de la ley hay un momento donde
todo eso cambia un momento y un
protagonista pablo escobar gaviria
considerado por la revista forbes como
una de las mayores fortunas de su época
en todo el planeta según esta revista en
1987 pablo escobar gaviria era
propietario de una fortuna que superaba
los 2 mil millones de dólares de aquella
época y es que pablo escobar cambió
radicalmente la industria de los
narcóticos en todo el mundo
por un lado creo todo un entramado un
holding criminal que incluían negocios
como la extorsión el secuestro el
sicariato y por supuesto la actividad
estrella el tráfico de narcóticos todas
estas actividades estaban además
perfectamente integradas en una
estructura el cartel de medellín que
tenía organigrama claro una jerarquía
definida e incluso una distribución por
zonas con sus propios responsables al
mando algo así como si de franquicias o
sucursales se tratara
por otro lado amigos en lo que respecta
al que fue su negocio estrella los
narcóticos este cartel el cartel de
medellín logró una integración vertical
casi completa es decir el cartel se
hacía cargo de la cosecha la producción
la distribución y la comercialización de
la inmensa mayor parte de su mercancía
lo hacían todo copaban todas las etapas
del negocio
de esta forma es como el cartel de
medellín logró facturar más de siete mil
siete mil millones de dólares de la
época cada año claro que un momento nada
de esto hubiera sido posible sin la
complicidad de los poderes públicos
aparentemente escobar alcanzó la cima
del cártel de la cocaína al reinvertir
astutamente sus ganancias iniciales y
convertirse en un maestro de las
relaciones públicas en colombia con su
creciente riqueza escobar compró un
periódico en medellín ganó influencia en
la política colombiana y se postuló con
éxito a un cargo público convirtiéndose
en una alternativa para el congreso
nacional david henrie revista forbes
[Música]
veréis durante muchos años pablo escobar
gozó de impunidad con su dinero y sus
amenazas la conocida frase de plata o
plomo logró infiltrarse en el estado
colombiano soborno a militares políticos
gobernadores policías de tal forma que
muchas de las instituciones colombianas
estuvieran durante mucho tiempo a su
orden y mando y eso no es todo pablo
escobar también financió campañas
electorales y para ganarse el apoyo
popular que hace un político cuando
quiere ganar popularidad por la vía
rápida impulsó proyectos como la
construcción de viviendas para los más
pobres el reparto de víveres y el
desarrollo de campos de fútbol
[Música]
suena bien verdad a primera vista todo
un robin hood colombiano lástima que la
realidad fuera tan diferente mientras
llevaba a cabo este tipo de campañas
este criminal no tuvo reparos en inundar
las calles con violencia y sangre
bienvenidos al narco populismo el caso
es que como todos sabéis pablo escobar
llegó en 1982 a ostentar un escaño en el
parlamento colombiano hasta ese momento
gracias a sus influencias políticas y a
sus estrategias de relaciones públicas
este personaje pudo construir su imperio
es inmensa fortuna con la más absoluta
impunidad un miembro de la agencia
antidrogas de eeuu dijo una vez que la
importación de animales exóticos para su
zoológico parecía haberle generado a
escobar más problemas frente al gobierno
que su negocio de narcóticos david
henrie ahora bien un momento no penséis
que las relaciones políticas de pablo
escobar se limitaban a colombia para
nada fijaos tras su elección como
diputado la situación se hizo
insostenible algunos medios de
comunicación empezaron a contar la
verdad que se escondía tras su fortuna
las presiones de la dea se multiplicaron
buena parte de la sociedad colombiana
comprendió definitivamente el enorme
peligro que entrañaba pablo escobar y
otros carteles empezaron a sentir pavor
de que el poder de medellín creciera aún
más y ahí fue cuando el gobierno comenzó
la persecución contra este capo que ni
corto ni perezoso le declaró la guerra
al mismísimo estado colombiano y por si
acaso lo primero que hizo fue largarse
no sea que le fueran a cazar
[Música]
el salto
y amigos en un primer momento pablo
escobar puso tierra de por medio se
largó de colombia y la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es donde podría
encontrar refugio serían los dólares del
narcotráfico suficientes para estrechar
alianzas pues lo cierto es que parece
que si en primer lugar
panamá en aquel momento el dictador
militar manuel antonio noriega le
ofreció asilo protección y también una
ruta para poder transportar su mercancía
imaginaos y esta industria era poderosa
que hasta los dictadores estaban
dispuestos a vender sus servicios el
caso es que como veis noriega también
convirtió a panamá en un narcoestado
hasta que en 1989 una invasión relámpago
de eeuu le depuso del poder detenido y
trasladado a los eeuu el propio noriega
fue condenado a 30 años de cárcel por
sus vínculos con el tráfico de
narcóticos y con el propio cártel de
medellín
o no aquí no terminan las salidas
exteriores de pablo escobar gaviria lo
cierto es que en panamá no se sentía muy
seguro vamos a ver si noriega por así
decirlo era un colega pero la cia tenía
mucha presencia en el país así que el
día menos esperado noriega podría tener
la tentación de venderle porque claro
una cosa es hacer negocios con el
dictador panameño y otra muy diferente
confiarle su protección tocaba buscar un
nuevo destino de esta forma a través de
la guerrilla colombiana de izquierdas
movimiento 19 de abril más conocido como
m-19 o simplemente como lm pablo escobar
se puso en contacto con el gobierno de
nicaragua la junta de gobierno
sandinista liderada por el actual
presidente del país daniel ortega estaba
dispuesta a recibirle con los brazos
abiertos a cambio de una comisión ya
sabéis por los servicios prestados el
acuerdo contemplaba que pablo podría
utilizar algunas regiones de nicaragua
como plataforma de distribución para los
narcóticos además de instalarse en el
país junto a su familia el problema
ortega y compañía eran muy codiciosos
así que unos meses después
pablo decidió regresar a colombia claro
que las relaciones de negocio se
mantuvieron junto a nicaragua a la
guerrilla m-19 también facilitó el
contacto del cártel de medellín con el
gobierno de cuba
tal cual como lo escucháis cuba fue
también una plataforma de operaciones
para los negocios de pablo escobar de
hecho se sabe que pablo escobar mantenía
buenas relaciones con los hermanos
castro que cobraban tanto por utilizar
la isla como centro de distribución como
por utilizarla como centro de
almacenamiento aunque la verdad parece
que no fue el único todo apunta a que
después de escobar otros narcos
continuaron utilizando cuba acuerdo con
castró mediante para introducir todo
tipo de narcóticos en los eeuu en fin
amigos colombia-panamá a nicaragua cuba
ya lo veis el propio poder político fue
uno de los principales impulsores de la
enorme presencia que el narco tiene en
américa latina' la falta de
transparencia en la corrupción la falta
de contrapesos y las instituciones
débiles fueron un caldo de cultivo
perfecto para lo que con el paso de los
años se ha convertido en una de las
grandes pesadillas de toda la región y
si puede
esté pensando bueno enrique tanto tanto
pero al final pablo escobar cayó es
verdad pero lo cierto es que cuando un
capo cae eso no quiere decir que ocurra
lo mismo con la industria ni con sus
relaciones con el poder político
tenemos un vistazo a méxico
[Música]
el relevo
el principal cartel mexicano con el que
pablo escobar tuvo relaciones fue el
cártel de guadalajara liderado por
ernesto fonseca que no tiene nada que
ver con nuestro fonseca por rafael caro
quintero y miguel ángel félix gallardo
este cartel amigos gozó de plena
impunidad durante dos décadas todo
gracias a sus relaciones con el poder
veréis félix gallardo era el encargado
de las relaciones públicas y digamos que
gracias a su capacidad para moverse en
las altas esferas políticas este cartel
tuvo toda la estabilidad y tranquilidad
para crecer y desarrollarse que
importante es tener un buen relaciones
públicas
sin embargo estamos hablando de una
industria criminal y en las
organizaciones criminales la estabilidad
es muy difícil en este caso el asalto al
agente de la dea enrique camarena que
terminó con su vida
supuso que washington exigiera la
desarticulación de este cartel y uno a
uno sus líderes fueron cayendo pero no
se terminó con el negocio desde la
cárcel en 1989
félix gallardo trató de reorganizar los
territorios pero ante la falta de
acuerdo el cartel se dividió en dos por
un lado el cártel de tijuana liderado
por los hermanos arellano y por otro el
cártel de sinaloa liderado por héctor
luís palma salazar el güero palma y
joaquín guzmán loera alias el chapo que
en el año 2009 debutó en la lista forbes
con una fortuna estimada de más de mil
millones de dólares
el caso es que bajo el mando del chapo
el cártel de sinaloa se convirtió en el
cártel más importante e influyente de
todo méxico y en una de las
organizaciones criminales más
importantes del planeta y claro la
pregunta que seguro alguno de vosotros
está haciendo es como lo logró como un
cartel puede conseguir crecer mucho más
que sus adversarios al fin y al cabo
venden todos lo mismo pues sobre todo
por las influencias políticas por
ejemplo como evitas que la policía
federal te atrape y desmantele tu
negocio pues por ejemplo enterando te de
cuándo se van a producir esas redadas
todo pasa por tener buenas relaciones y
eso es precisamente lo que el chapo se
aseguró de tener la información y los
amigos son poder y tal y como ya hemos
visto en otros casos la captura del
chapo no cambió esencialmente el
panorama hoy el cartel de sinaloa es
controlado por ismael 'el mayo' zambada
que según se sabe a lo largo del tiempo
ha logrado comprar incluso a
funcionarios de la fiscalía
especializada de la procuraduría general
de la república y hasta del centro de
inteligencia antinarcóticos un cuerpo de
élite del ejército creado para luchar
precisamente contra los narcos
obviamente que esos negocios no los
hacen solos sino que no pocos casos
cuentan con la aprobación o
participación de autoridades
efe/j ere investigador de la universidad
de guadalajara ya lo veis todo siempre
con la complicidad de altos cargos de
gobierno así y sólo así se explica el
poder la fuerza y la resiliencia de
estos grupos criminales con el apoyo del
poder político con el cual en muchos
casos crean una simbiosis difícil de
distinguir es lo que está ocurriendo en
venezuela con el cartel de los soles del
que ya os hemos hablado aquí en visual
político y ojo porque se calcula que
entre los carteles mexicanos y
venezolanos controlan el 70 por ciento
de los narcóticos que entran en los eeuu
es también lo mismo que ocurre en países
como guatemala donde algunas
informaciones apuntan ojo que hasta un
80 un 80 por ciento de los polvos
blancos podrían ser intermediados por
miembros del propio ejército o lo que
ocurre en honduras donde incluso el hijo
del ex presidente porfirio lobo ha sido
condenado en los eeuu por actividades de
narcotráfico mientras
su padre su propio padre era el
mismísimo presidente de la república en
fin amigos este es el resultado de las
instituciones débiles de la falta de
transparencia y de la falta de
contrapesos aquí en visual política
hablaremos mucho de esta cuestión que
tan cara está resultando para muchos
países latinoamericanos con este vídeo
os hemos querido mostrar unas pinceladas
de cómo algunos de los grandes narcos
consiguieron su éxito en gran medida
gracias a su influencia sobre las
instituciones si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte a visual político un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]